This is an accusation that people throw at you,
and then it's your responsibility to issue an apology for something
you never even encountered in your life. And then to defend yourself.
And even we got a lot of messages saying, well,
now you should donate money to any of the black lives matter causes.
And that to me is it's extortion.
Hey, I'm Dave Rubin and it's small business week here on the Rubin report.
Joining me today is Anna [inaudible] co owner of cuchara restaurant
in Houston, Texas. Anna, welcome to the show.
I thank you. Thank you for having me.
Yeah, my pleasure. I'm glad to have you,
because I want it to have someone in the restaurant business,
because I think you guys are dealing with some seriously unique problems.
Uh, so first off, just tell us a little bit about why you started cuchara.
How long have you guys been in business,
and then you've done some super interesting things during lockdown to stay
successful. Uh, so I want to get into that as well.
Perfect. Well, uh, the restaurant is going to be eight years old, the September,
uh, the concept behind it is every time I go to Mexico,
I craved my grandmother's food. My aunt's food. I don't pray, but chef, uh,
so that's a concept.
We have all female staff in the kitchen and they're all moms from Mexico.
They all cook from all right.
They have so much passion and they care for fresh ingredients.
And they're crazy for that. So basically they arrive,
they cook traditional recipes without any lists, and then they go home.
That's the principle. That's how I always wanted to be a,
an all female kitchen to bring really the flavors of
the Mexican food that I grew up with. So that's how it'll start there. Um,
our anniversary is September 15, which is Mexico's independence,
very not known for many Americans, but that is Mexican independence,
September 15. So if, uh, we,
then we're going to have a big celebration this year. Again,
hopefully all these, uh, COVID thing will be gone by then. Um,
and basically the concept for the restaurant besides fresh food and e-mails is
to also bring culture like Mexican celebrations to Houston,
so people can understand and see what Mexico truly is about. Um,
during that COVID-19 of course we were forced to close our dining room and
patio.
So we started because people know that we do lots of different events and lots
of different parties. We kind of wanted to bring those to the home.
So we did classes online to play Loteria and prepare folktales or to
make the malice along with one of my books. Um,
we did a lot of different little events for regulars,
where we created like an ID on. So it was private just for them.
Uh, we also need a YouTube channel.
So we posted the tamales class or some other little things.
We try to keep people engaged because, um,
we are in the middle of a very international, eclectic neighborhood.
And we have a lot of clients and majority the ones that support those day by
day, they're single.
They come to the restaurant because they met new people from all over the world,
new friends,
and they felt that solely of not being able to come to us as what they would
usually do. So we tried to stay in touch with them via Facebook,
or doing little events with them and creating different
packages for them to pick up and learn how to make rice boating or a size with a
mortar.
We did lots of little events so that people felt engaged and they could
see the other regulars. At least if it wasn't a pool.
So you started as a restaurant tour and you became a YouTuber in the midst of
coronavirus.
No, I didn't really want it, but we had to.
And how has business been through making some of these changes?
You know, it was really challenging, but it worked. I mean, we,
we cannot complain.
Our sales were not as terrible as we thought they would be in our minds.
We never wanted anyone to have to be for low or for them to have
to go get unemployment. We just really wanted to keep everyone in, in our staff.
We love everyone in our staff.
We have 52 employees and I just didn't want to be suffering.
We'd been organized. Uh, so we, we didn't have to worry about it.
We were able to do payroll even before the current account.
So everyone was grateful and thankful and happy to have a doc,
even though it was just a very few weeks, very few hours per week,
compared to the long hours where it used to. But you know, it worked fine.
As I said, the sales were not that disappointing.
And once we were allowed to reopen, then we started going up again.
So I would say it affected those,
but not as bad as we thought or as other fellow restaurateurs have
suffered.
Yeah.
Are you worried as a small business owner that even though you guys survived
this one and you did some, some cool, fun things to make it through that,
you know,
we could get a second wave where there could just be some other thing that,
that kind of puts you out again and you know, like all small business owners,
you don't have a giant corporation that can kind of keep you afloat in these
rough times.
Correct? Yeah. We're scared about, you know,
the CD deciding to close this again. Uh,
right now we're dealing with a lot of problems because of the social distancing.
Uh, some people tell you one thing, some people tell you another,
there's really not a very good communication system with the government,
with the rules and regulations follow, um,
which led to like another big problem we have, um,
they want us to keep six feet distance abled, which we've done.
So even if we're supposed to be open at seven 10,
it doesn't work for us because our restaurant is not huge.
So by keeping the six foot distance, we are open at 50% capacity when,
when we're very like full and happy because of the distance.
Um,
following all the protests for George Floyd and whatnot,
where social distance was totally relevant.
My business partner made a comment or personal Facebook saying, well,
I guess the social distancing is not enforced.
So the mayor and the chief of police went to a parade where nothing
was enforced.
And we started getting upset because he called it up parade instead of a
March, which is basically, I don't know, just a technicality.
That didn't mean anything. He could have used another soccer game,
anything just to prove that the government is not helping us with regulations.
Uh, but these malicious person was sending his comment to all these
activists and all those people that are ready.
Don't but only in your racist when you're not.
So we started getting these, I guess, bombard, uh,
mints and ugly, you know, even death threats and, um,
people requesting that he would give an apology for being a racist,
but he's like, no,
I'm not going to give an apology because I'm not a racist again. Uh,
black friends of ours getting threats or being our friends.
These really truly became crazy way more than the
COVID-19 would have ever heard those.
It was this action of malicious people just pointing the finger and saying
that my business partner is so racist that he goes to like blacks,
that he doesn't like Mexicans when we are all Mexican in the restaurant,
except for him.
And just calling him overly names like white supremacist cookbooks plan
member, when all he did was use the word parade,
which was a word, uh,
Reverend Lawson referred to in the event.
It is a Reverend that Lloyd's family chose to speak. And he called it.
Well, did he? He called it a parade. So actually,
so I'm glad you transitioned into that because, you know, we got,
we got hundreds of people that wanted to do small business. We can,
and obviously lots of restaurant tours that did some interesting things,
but I thought this part of your story,
when I read this is the next level of all of this that you guys,
you survive through, COVID you do what you have to do.
And then your business partner makes a completely, uh,
absolutely fine statement. We can all debate the word parade or not.
Even though, as you're saying,
the Reverend at the funeral actually said the word parade, but putting that,
but now you're under a different type of attack and literally thousands of
messages. And I saw some of them and, and death threats and,
and the rest of it in many ways, I think you just sort of alluded to this.
Do you view this as more of a danger as a small business person then than the
other stuff?
Definitely. Definitely. Because this is an accusation that people throw at you,
and then it's your responsibility to issue an apology for something
you you've never even encountered in your life. And then to defend yourself.
And even we got a lot of messages saying, well,
now you should donate money to any of the black lives matter causes.
And that to me is it's extortion because we're in no position to donating
anything, to anyone,
but our employees and just to survive and to keep the business running.
But now we have all these special really weird interests,
bogging us to try to make us donate to specific causes that
we don't, we didn't even know existed because as again, in our minds,
we've never been someone that could be accused of being a racist or,
or a discriminator in any way or manner.
So it is just frustrating.
It's frustrating to see how many people stand behind our people like that,
that just use their keyboard as their weapon. They're in other States,
they're not even people from Houston,
they're people from Atlanta and people from California,
people from Detroit and from whatever places that have never,
probably even been in Texas.
And they they're jump in and accuse us of being racist when we
were not.
You and your business partner are standing up for it. And I promise you,
you know, I was supposed to be on a book tour and had to stop in Houston.
So when we reschedule it, I will definitely have dinner with you guys.
And now just to close out,
if I'm going to the restaurant in Houston, what am I having for dinner?
Plan me the perfect meal. Tell me the perfect meal.
Now I know there's going to be a margarita there,
but give me what's the perfect meal that I would.
You're going to start with a fresh margarita.
All our ingredients are fresh every single day. We don't freeze anything.
So every whatever you have is going to be amazing,
but I would definitely make you try it. Greece people take the tacos,
which come in a very spicy salad side that is very kind to make,
even though it looks simple, you'll attest to the flavor.
You'll probably have the pork and the Lord with Molly, our black or green.
Molly's my favorite. It's my grandma's recipe.
And I think that's besides the best salary.
That's my favorite thing in the menu.
You probably will try a few sites like the shape porn or the
corn duress. And then at the cert,
we have many different desserts and I would recommend this in colleges because
it, why.
I've never heard of Cinco. I know there was trace.
I did not know that was even possible.
You will fall in love. It's delicious. Wow. Two extra.
Late shades. Okay. All right. Well, Anna, thank you so much.
It's cuchara restaurant in Houston, Texas.
I wish you guys a lot of luck and don't worry.
I promise you if I know one thing you will survive the mob and you guys will
come out better on the other side. Thank you so much.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.